hey everyone it's Mike from amorphos
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you can join me for today's video
we're going to be talking about point of
controls and finding out which point of
controls in the order flow uh matter the
most now
before I jump in you know if you've been
enjoying these videos be sure to
subscribe to the channel and you know
leave your comments in the comment
section below of what you uh find useful
out of this video or potentially some
videos that you'd like to see me make in
the future and you know it's that sort
of that feedback that interaction that
really gives me that motivation to make
more videos for you so let's go ahead
and get started and talk about today's
topic of point of control so you know in
the order flow
right you have a bar okay I mean every
bar has volume basically traded at most
levels and the price level in the bar
where the most volume trades
is the point of control right on a
footprint chart right now you know on a
volume profile chart
um you know on your individual profile I
think I got one over here somewhere uh
here we go you know every bar is going
to have a point of control level okay
but on the actual footprint chart
right every bar you can see has a level
where the heaviest volume was and we
call that the point of control some
Traders excuse me
um you know some of the older traders
that uh you know been trading order flow
for over 10 years sometimes they refer
to it as the cot the commitment of
Traders but it's basically the same
thing right it's the price level in the
bar where the most volume traded on the
bid and the offer added together
and there's no big fancy calculation
other than adding the price
adding the volume that traded on the bid
at one
on uh you know at one level and the
offer at the same level okay and
obviously the price level with most
volume that is your point of control now
every bar has one but not every bar is
point of control
in my opinion has any influence on the
market
majority of the times it's going to
appear somewhere around the middle of
the bar which is what you would expect
right you'd expect sort of the the
middle area of the bar you know where
the value is where the value is going to
form sort of the midpoint of the bar but
there are times where they appear you
know near the low of the bar near the
high of the bar
um
and sometimes those matter sometimes
they don't I'm gonna sort of get into
the types of point of controls that I
like now
when I did my point of control analysis
years ago I was more using range-based
charts so you know like I like eight
range charts I like four range charts I
like four range charts on slower moving
markets you know a market like gold
um currencies uh e-minis I like eight
range charts and you know I've been
getting a lot of comments from from
Traders asking me to spend some more
time on Range based charts as opposed to
um you know the vanilla time based
charts that I've usually been using so
this is a gold this is an eight range
chart and as you can see a lot of the
bars have the point of control somewhere
near the middle of the bar like here
this bar here is in the middle this bar
here it's like one tick below the middle
here it's in the middle here it's
towards the bottom end towards the
middle towards the middle towards the
middle towards the middle you know
middle part sand
that is it's sort of my opinion
um is that you know sort of Traders
discount the importance of point of
control because there are so often
seeing it in the middle of the bar they
just sort of expected it's almost like
it's in their way of doing their
analysis of the order flow but there are
times right and I call I've written
about this I call these pointed controls
on the extremes of a bar okay and what
that looks like let me see if there's
one here
is this right you have a green candle a
green up candle
and the point of control is on the very
bottom of the bar
okay so I know the heaviest volume
in this bar this green up candle a
appeared at
the low of the bar
so what's that mean to me
well
if it's coming after a move right here's
your high of the day we pull back a
little bit we run down into this area
you know the high was what 46.50 1946
and a half gets down to 43.80 so you
know almost a three dollar move and it
just stops right here and reverses and
goes back up well
when I see a point of control on a green
bar at the bottom of the bar it's
telling me that there was
some support coming in okay now people
can say well it's only 23 contracts on
the bid you know eight on the offer it's
not that heavy this bar only trade 136
contracts at the time right the market
came back it was just enough to stop
this move and essentially reverse it now
we get back up here you see we hit a new
high all the way at 47.70 we do have a
point of control on the extreme of a red
bar it's down the top of a red bar so
what I'm going to look for is
at the top of a red candle or the bottom
of a green candle
and people say well this one just went
sideways okay I mean there's heavy
volume here 198 on the offer which is
quite strong in gold at one price level
especially on a range base chart you
know Market started to come back off
sort of came back up got through it by
two ticks and then came off you know
whatever a buck and a half and then
reversed and went back up but
it's not just that you have it on the
extreme and this is where I see a lot of
Traders sort of run into problems using
point of controls on the extremes is
they're not taken in context this is in
a market that's going sideways right we
had just traded there two bars earlier
prior to that two bars earlier here is
after a move right I mean it's a smaller
move you know a bucket you know from
what uh you know 46 and a half down to
43.80
but here this is not a move this is
sideways activity where it's coming in
here you know you where you want them to
come in is at highs swing highs or swing
lows not just anywhere you have one on
the extreme so let me see if there's any
other ones on the day before or not
mm-hmm
this is again this is gold and you get
one here it's just one tick off the high
right here just one tick off the low but
really what I like to see them on is on
the extreme right on the high of a red
candle at the high of the day not as
you're going into the low of the day
right there's one right down here okay
this is a red candle
let me just up my chart here right it's
a red candle
point of control on the extreme but we
literally sold off you know from our
highs up here down to the low of the day
then you get that that's not where I
want if I'm going to be looking for a
point of control on the extreme I'm
gonna be looking for a green candle
somewhere near the low
either when the low is made or as we're
starting to move away from the low not
in a red candle after we've been selling
off uh quite strongly
well let's just see if there's any more
again I'm just sort of going through
this I threw up this chart
um earlier here is pointing control on
the extreme now this was obviously
during the FED uh during Powell's
talking at Jackson Hole
right 902 40. this is all 902 41. I mean
I don't know if you would have been able
to take advantage of that but maybe by
the time you get long it's Marcus
already trading 41.50 but that's sort of
you know you can see how the market
found that liquidity right because you
know in a fast Market markets will stop
when it finds liquidity then it's going
to reverse and hit that liquidity so
it's tell me there's a strong buyer down
here
okay
up here again this is from Powell
started speaking but this is a green
candle with the point of control on the
top that's not what I'm looking for for
a green candle I'm looking for the point
of control on the bottom if it was a red
candle if this red candle had the point
of control on the top that's what I
would look for it'd be getting short not
a green candle with the point of control
at the at the top
um okay let's take a look you know
another Market I like to look at and
deal with point of control is because
you know point of controls deal with
volume okay is
bonds 10 years
you know even fives take a look at the
tens really quick here
again it's not something you're going to
see every single day in every single
Market time after time but here you have
the low of the day
horny control you got it's a green
candle part of control on the very
bottom so this is telling me I mean I
could tell by the ratio that there's
support coming in here there's enough
stopping volume in this market to arrest
this move down
and potentially reverse it back up which
it did in this case right you see 2700
34 plus 1203 okay so it's strong volume
down here there's there's a buyer down
here willing to absorb all the selling
that was taking place down here at at
the low of the day 109.03 and a half
um let's see if there was any bearish
ones and again you know in different
markets right
uh currencies I actually I don't like a
four range Charter like an eight range
chart in the euro currency
um let's see just sort of go through
here real quick if there's any
but again it's not about this is going
to give you a bunch of trade setups
every single day it's about you know
when you see it happening on your chart
you can take advantage of it
okay here again this is round this is on
uh Friday but still it's 904.49 you know
you do have a couple minutes about a
minute to take advantage of it it's
after Powell started speaking you know
the market really went nuts around nine
around nine o'clock then again at 902
this is at 904 almost 905 opponent
control right there on the top of the
bar right 41 contracts trade up here at
the high of the day doesn't seem like
much but at this point it's enough to
satisfy all the liquidity that was
looking you know being searched for in
the markets right and it was enough to
cause to stop that move it's it's I'm
not saying that there's so much selling
pressure coming into the market that is
stopping it was enough that one
it's enough to absorb whatever buying
was there and exhausted in the sense of
the buying aggressive buying that was
taking place is now done
okay that's the point I'm trying to make
now in other markets like say e uh
e-minis
okay Imani's is a market that
distributes volume
fairly well in the sense that you're not
going to get very many if any uh point
of controls on the extremes you know
either at the top of red bar or bottom
of a green bar that's just an
observation that I've noticed uh you
know over the last couple years
especially on a range based chart you
might get it on a time-based chart but
on a range based chart
um you know Market this Market e-mini's
distributes the volume uh pretty well
when you start getting into a little bit
more some of the more other stock
indices
um ym
again I you know ym moves enough I don't
know if I'd use an eight range chart
maybe a 10 range chart
I haven't looked at it today
so I don't know if there was any on a 10
range chart but you know oftentimes
you're going to see the market hit an
area of liquidity and just sort of stop
on a dime and reverse
okay I don't know if it was any today
here I mean
Market sold off right this is a move
from 614 all the way down to 533 80
point sell-off
hits this area is just enough 17 was
just enough to finish absorbing whatever
aggressive selling was taking place and
cause a little bit of a bounce right I
mean you know was it a massive move no I
was a move from about 47 or 50 you know
back up it did get as high as what 73
but you know more or less you know
a small move
is there anything else here on the this
is ym
that's going back to the morning time
now uh but again you know that's on uh
10 range chart if you look on an eight
range chart obviously it's going to be
slightly different
okay Mike I don't know if it's still
going to appear there
this morning
you know one thing that I have noticed
is uh when you're looking yeah see it's
not even there on the because I think it
was right around this nah I think it was
around that time I can't remember now
um
when you're looking at it you know when
you change your range on your chart
obviously it's going to make the chart
look a little bit different now people
will ask but what about this one here
okay
558 I mean this is what I like to see on
a red candle
but you know we're sort of it's sort of
on the upper end of this range that
we're trading in right basically between
29 and 58 we had already just been
trading 58 this is not even 10 minutes
ago it's like six minutes or prior
that we're trading that level
so hopefully you start to see get the
idea I'm just going through markets here
at random crude oil I like crude oil on
an eight range chart as well let's take
a look I mean I I again I haven't looked
at the crew chart on any range to see if
there was any but again the whole point
of this video is sort of to teach you
that when you see it you know what to do
with it okay again this one is sort of
in this area that we had just been
trading I would prefer it if it came in
up here rather than right down here
you know it's always good to trade
things in context of the market in the
sense of where the high or the low is so
this was last night okay Sunday night
you see this Market selling off it's
about nine o'clock Chicago time 904 PM
last night Sunday night
strong selling in the market
gets down here and it stops and it
reverses point of control right on the
bottom of this green candle at the low
of the day it's enough to absorb
whatever selling is taking place there
right you can even see here on the offer
103 Lots on the offer and the market is
finally the sellers they had no more to
do they gave up they they got no more
selling I mean there was they were quite
aggressive selling it all on the way
down then it gets down here
and
they they can't push it any lower why
because they got no more bullets they're
done their gun is empty so to speak and
then the market Works its way back up
right from you know the 79 8182 area
back all the way up you know another 40
quick 40 cents in
you know by the time Europe is open
so
you know that's going to wrap up this
video on point of control
um you know extreme point of controls
looking for them as stopping volume
again it's not just about taking every
single one that appears you want to put
it in context right you want to see it
coming in after a move that that happens
you know on the way down you're gonna
look for the bullish ones or bearish
ones after a move back up
um you know and again it's not something
as you can see I went through a bunch of
markets it's not something you see all
the time but really you know if you're
going to take one thing away from this
video what I want you to do is go
through your charts look at them start
expanding it not just point control on
the extreme start looking at Point
controls at slightly different levels
and go from there because that's how
you know dyr right do your research uio
or do your own research
um you know for your crypto guys is
you're going to find that you're going
to start seeing things happening over
and over as the markets find turning
points and it's uncanny in the sense
that
you see this happening time in and time
out all right so thanks again everyone
and I'll catch you on the next video
bye-bye